(curious instrumental music)
- I've dedicated my life
to studying the ocean,
but sometimes you come
across something so marvelous
you have to wonder,
"What the heck is going on down here?"
Today we're talking
about the mimic octopus.
- [Others] Mimic octopus.
(curious instrumental music)
- Octopuses are rather curious creatures.
When exposed, they're
vulnerable to predators
so typically, they like to stay hidden.
When they do move they do so
by walking along the ocean's
floor on their eight legs.
(curious instrumental music)
But in 1998, scientists
discovered an octopus
residing in the shallow
waters of Indonesia
doing something quite strange.
Over the course of two years,
they filmed it and nine
other similar octopuses
mimicking behaviors of at
least three different species.
They found it swimming,
its legs outstretched
high above the ocean floor
like a lion fish,
flattened out gliding over
the bottom like a flat fish,
and extending its tentacles to
mimic a poisonous sea snake.
This allows the mimic octopus
to hide in plain sight.
Astonishing.
(captivating instrumental music)